[Müzik]
gökkuşağının altından geçersen
Cinsiyetin değişir derler hiç duydunuz
mu Bu lafı Ben küçükken Halamdan
duymuştum Bunu o da çocukken her
Gökkuşağı geçti bulduğunda Gökkuşağı
çıktığında altından geçmeye çalışırmış
ve sonra da becerebildin mi diye
cinsiyeti değiştim diye kontrol edermiş
çocuğuna Bunu yaptıran ne biliyor
musunuz daha o yaşta erkek olmanın daha
avantajlı bir şey olduğunu fark etmiş
olmak
erkek dediğimiz standart bir insandır
görünmezdir erkek kelimesi bir şeyin
başını erkek getirmezseniz ama biz onun
erkek olduğunu biliriz mühendis dersiniz
o erkektir kadın mühendisliği Ayrıca
belirtirsiniz kadın Kaymakam kadın pilot
kadın polis bir şeyin başında erkek
getirmezseniz zaten o defa erkektir
ve insan standardı standart insan derken
bunu kastediyorum
küçük bir çocuğa bir insan çizsene
dersin çöp adam çizer mesela adam kelime
kendinden cinsiyetli ya da kardan insan
yaparız mesela kardan adamdır onunladı
Es kaza kardan kadın yaparsın o bir
şaheser Ayrıca parmakla gösterilmesi
gerekir Çünkü sıra dışı bir şey yapmış
olursunuz Zencefilli Kurabiye Adam bile
erkek yine adam bakın
İnsanoğlu diyoruz oğul kelimesi var
içinde İngilizcesi de men adam türü İşte
insan standardı erkek derken bundan
bahsediyorum kadın ise onun
cinsiyetlendirilmiş hali gibi bir
standart insan var erkek bir cinsiyet
verirseniz O da kadın oluyor
ve bir insanın cinsiyetini
belirtmezseniz erkek olduğu kabul edilir
ama daha önemli ise erkek olması tercih
edilir
aterkil toplumda bir kadının kadın
olarak doğması demek olması gereken
Cinsiyette doğmamış kadın olmuş ve bu o
ve ailesi için üzücü üzüntü vermiş üzücü
bir şey
içerisinde babamla bir toplantıya
gitmiştik yine herkesin erkek olduğu bir
toplantı
babamı daha önce tanıyan biri geldiği
yanına Senin küçük kız mı diye beni
gösterdi babam Hayır benim Üç kızım var
bu ortanca dedi adam babamın omzuna
dokundu olsun dedi ben yanlarındayken
babamın üç kızı olduğu için üzüldüğünü
hiç hissetmedim Ama babam için
üzüldüklerine çok şahit oldum bu üç kız
bilgisi böyle acı bir haber gibiydi
babamın üç kızı olması üzücü bir şey
babamın teselli edilmesi gerek Ya bir
kız çocuğuna Senin sadece varlığın
ailenin için üzüntü verici bir şey
deniyor bunun ağırlığına Duyabiliyor
musunuz
oğlan doğurmak bir zafer bir coşkulu bir
haber bunu deyimi bile var ne bu
sessizlik kız mı doğdu
ve oğlan doğurmak öyle bir zafer mutlaka
elde edilmesi gereken bir müjde olduğu
için
çabaladım elde edilmesi gereken bir şey
yeşilçamın Gülen Gözler filmi vardır
bilirsiniz ismiyle Bilmez Kimse de
Vecihi var hani uçağıyla Uçar falan evin
etrafında o film işte
O filmdeki babanın 5 tane kızı var
hepsinin ismi de Hikmet İsmet Fikret
gibi erkek isimleri çünkü hep oğlu
olacak sanıyor eşi hamileyken öyle isim
düşünüyor ama kızı oluyor Yine de ismi
koyu veriyor falan tekrar deniyor tekrar
deniyor oğlanı bulana kadar bulacak o
olanı Çünkü kız olması yetmiyor 4 tane
kızı olması yeterli değil bu yeterli
olmamanın altını Duyabiliyor musunuz 4
tane oğlu olan bir aile bir de kızı
olsun diye tekrar Tekrar dener mi işte
kız çocuk olmanın ağırlığını hissettiren
yerler buralar
erkek olmak tercih edilir ve bazı haklar
erkeklere otomatik tahsis edilir
Bunlardan biri dışarıda Olmaktır
dışarısı erkeklerin alanıdır para
kazanabiliyor olmak Dışarıda para
kazanabiliyor olmak erkeklere otomatik
tahsis edildiler bir haktır
Biz şimdi yaşadığımız eve taşındığımızda
komşularla tanışırken önce ismimi
sordular sonra çalışıyor musun diye
sordular bana
kimse bunu sormadı Çünkü erkeklere bu
sorulmaz erkeklere Ne iş yapıyorsun diye
Sorulur yetişkin bir erkeğin zaten
çalışıyor olduğunu varsayarız yetişkin
erkeklerin çalışmıyor olması sıra
dışıdır Hatta ayıplanır Nasıl yani
çalışmıyor musun
iş hayatı bu böyle söylenmez adı böyle
konmaz ama erkeklerin sahasıdır onların
doğal habitatıdır erkeklerin ait olduğu
yer ev değil iş yeridir
Yine bir gün toplantıya gitmiştim Bu kez
tek başıma yine Benden Başka kadın yok
toplantıda ama böyle çok uluslu bir
markanın bir bayi toplantısı çok lüks
Bir otelde üst düzey bir yönetici
yapıyor toplantıyı ve rakamlarda kötü
gidiyor satışlar böyle bayileri kızdığı
bir veri var ekranda sonra bir an durdu
ve şey dedi Şimdi bir şeyler dedim Ama
aramızda Hanımlar var beni kastederek
o an şeyden emin oldum demek İlk defa
bir kadın var bu toplantıda bundan
önceki toplantılar hep erkeklerin kendi
arasında yaptığı toplantıymış ve ben
olmasam ne diyecekti acaba diye düşündüm
Küfür mü ediyorlar toplantılarda iş
hayatı böyle erkeklerin jargonlarının
erkeklerin kurallarının olduğu bir yer
onların sahası ve Sizin orada olmanız
garipseniyor kadın böyle parmakla
gösterilen ve
kalitenen bir yerde oluyorsunuz
iş hayatı kadınlara göre organize
edilmiş değil Henüz Çünkü Dışarıda kimse
hevesi de değil organize etmeye Ben bir
avukatım ve sabah evden çıkarken
Bakırköy'e gideceksem ona göre
giyiniyorum
Etiler'e gideceksem ona göre
gardırobunda İstanbul'da
giyebileceklerim ve Tatil beldelerinde
giyebileceklerim diye ayrı bölümler var
Benim pek çok başka kadın gibi
giyebileceklerim bakın giyeceklerim
değil bu benim tercihime bırakılmış bir
yerde değil hiçbir erkek meslektaşımın
sabah evden çıkarken gideceğiz semte
göre kıyafetini seçmekle kafasını meşgul
ettiğini sanmıyorum böyle bir gündemi
Yok onun Çünkü dışarı çıkmakla ilgili
mesela Eşinizin dışarıda olması ve
dışarının kamusal alanın erkeklere
tahsis edilmesiyle alakalı bir mesele bu
yine Hukuk Fakültesi mezunlarını düşünün
Avukat olurlar
noter olurlar akademisyen olurlar Hadi
hakim de olurlar ama çok nadir Savcı
olurlar Neden Çünkü Savcı olay
mahallinde çalışır savcının işini
yaptığı yer dışarısıdır Dolayısıyla
hangi mesleği yapıyor olursanız olun
kadın olmakla birlikte o mesleğin
dışarıda icrası ekstra bir önem taşır ve
maruz kalmayan da bilmez Bunları ben de
bilinsin istiyorum bilinsin ki görünür
olsun görünür olsun ki beraber çağırıyor
seni
hukuk Fakültesinden mezun olmaya yakın
avukatlık stajımı yapmak için bir büro
ile görüşüyordum yine böyle gayet
Plazalar da kurumsal bir bir büro
görüşme bitti görüşme yapan kişi dedi ki
siz dava departmanına başvurmuşsunuz ama
biz oraya erkek stajyer arıyoruz Neden
dedi git Anadolu'da dosyalarımız var
dedim bir seyahat engelimi yok benim
Anadolu'ya gidebilirim ama dedim müvekil
erkek avukat görmek istiyor Bu erkek
avukat görmek istiyor onun altında ne
yatıyor biliyor musunuz sen bir kadınsın
ve kadın olduğun için
iyi yapamayacağına dair kuşkularımız var
işini çok da iyi yapamayacağına
inanıyoruz yani Dolayısıyla müvekil de
rahat rahat dosyasını sana emanet
edemeyecek Biz de bununla uğraşmak
istemeyiz
hukuk bürosunun kurduğu cümle hukuka
aykırı Biz erkek stajyer bakıyoruz demek
kanuna aykıra bakalım utanç verici
Herkes için iyi yaptığını ispat etmek
ister mü vekiline müdürüne patronuna
müşterisine Ben şimdi iyiyim ben bu işi
çok iyi yapıyorum bunu ispatlamaya
çalışırız doğru ama bir kadınsanız
ispatlayacağınız şey önünüzde Duran
Paket işinizi iyi yaptığınız değil
işinizi iyi yapamayacağınıza dair bir ön
kabul var böyle bir yargı var kadın ve
yapamayacak önce onu çürütmekle
başlarsınız işe Yani normalde sarf
edilecek enerjinin iki katını sarf
etmeniz gerekir Bunun yorgunluğunu
görebiliyor musunuz
bir erkeğin sarf etmesi gerekmeyen bir
çaba bu hiç maruz kalmadığı bir
yorgunluk bakın daha evli çocuklu kadın
olmaya gelmedik sadece kadın olmaktan
bahsediyoruz
Zor Bela işe girdik giriş
pozisyonlarında da olsa diyelim
yükselemiyoruz
terfi alamıyoruz
senin yarısından fazlası kadındı Türkiye
Barolar birliğinin verilerine göre bugün
kayıtlı 143 bin Avukat var bunun 78 bine
erkek 65 bini kadın yarı yarıya bir oran
neredeyse ve baroların meslek örgütü şey
avukatların meslek örgütü olan baroların
83 baronun 13'ünün başkanı kadın Yani bu
başkanlık pozisyonlarında Genel Müdürlük
pozisyonlarında üst düzey yönetici
pozisyonlarda kadınları göremiyoruz bir
iş yerinin çalışan sayısına bakıyorsun
Çok güzel yarı yarıya neredeyse 49'a 51
kadın çalışanlar yönetici seviyesine
geçiyorsun yüzde bire düşüyor ora %2'ye
düşüyor Kadınların yönetici
olamayacağına dair bir algı var sanki
yöneticilik becerileri g kromozomuyla
aktarılıyormuş gibi
ya böyle maruz kaldığınız yöneticileri
düşünün okul müdürünüzü düşünün çocuk
kerki patronunuzu düşünün ebeveyninizin
patronlarını düşünün yaşadığınız ülkenin
başkanını düşünün kaymakamını düşünün
yönetici olarak gördüğümüz profil Lider
profili hep Erkek hep erkeklerin
yönetici olabileceğine dair bir bilgiye
maruz kalıyoruz ve kadınların
yapamayacağı düşünülüyor yani Kadın
zaten beceremez iş hayatında kadınların
belli bir seviyenin üstüne çıkamamasına
dair bir terminoloji var cam tavan denir
duymuşsunuzdur çoğunuz diye tahmin
ediyorum bu terminolojiye göre kadınlar
belli bir seviyenin üstüne çıkamazlar bu
Adı Konmuş yazılı bir kural değildir
Dolayısıyla canı görünmezdir Ama mutlaka
bir engelle karşılaşırlar bir yere kadar
gelir üstüne çıkamaz
bir de bunu Can uçurum versiyonu var
Glass kılıf deniyor ona da o da şu;
işler kötüye gittiğinde durgunlaştığında
kriz anlarında işin başına bir kadının
geçirilmesi hali
Böylece beklenen fiyasko
gerçekleştiğinde Çünkü zaten kötü
gidiyor Zaten kriz var sorumlu tutulacak
kişi belli kadın yaratıcı kadını
yönetici yaparsan olacağı bu ve kadının
becerememesi beceremeyecek olması o
kadar beklendiktir ki
gerçekleştiğinde de köpürtülerek sunulur
kadın şoför dehşet saçtı trafik
kazalarının çoğu erkekler tarafından
yapılır Ama hiçbir haberde erkek sürücü
diye belirtildiğini görmezsiniz kadın
pilot kontrolündeki uçak düştü kadın
pilot olursa olacağı bu bu O dilde çok
bariz şekilde verilir ama aslında
Sinsice yedirilir
bir kadın için en ideal meslek
öğretmenlik de denir duymuşsunuzdur bunu
da mutlaka neden
iş yerlerinde Yani bu kaçınılmaz bir
şeyin çocuk bakımlı kadın yapacak iş
yerlerinde bunun kaçınılmazlığını
görünce diyor ki Ya kadın zaten evle
çocukla fazlasıyla meşgul olacak
Dolayısıyla ben ondan gereken randıman
alamayacağım gereken performansı
gösteremeyecek en iyisi Almayın ya da
İşe alayım Ama giriş pozisyonlarında
kalsın hiç terfi ettirmeyeyim daha
farklı fazla sorumluluk üstleneceği
pozisyonlara göndermeyeyim tabi maaşı da
artmasın böyle kendi kendini besleyen
bir sistem
mevcut sistemde kadınlara denen şu kadın
olduğun için zaten üzgünüz zaten Hayata
bir sıfır geriden başladın iş hayatında
da olmaman gerekiyordu Orası sana ait
değil sen oraya ait değilsin Hadi oldun
ama bak Beceremedin beceremiyorsun
Sen en iyisi evde kal evde de yapılacak
onca iş var bir çocuğa da en iyi annesi
bakar
Sen ev içi emeğini bedelsiz yıllık
izinsiz mesaisiz kıdem tazminatsız
ailene sun
Önce ağzına bir parmak bal çalacak
Cennet ayaklarının altında diyecek bu
yaptığın iş çok kutsal diyecek ama
Esasen seni dış dünyadan haberi olmayan
zor konulara aklı ermeyen bir yere
konumlandıracak küçümseyecek ilk
ihtilafta diyecek ki Bütün parayı ben
kazandım Sen bütün gün evdeydin sen mi
kazandın diyecek para Kazanan taraf
olarak iktidar kurmaya çalışacak
Kadınlar tüm ön kabullerden ön
yargılardan fazlası
Tüm bu ayrıcalıklar ayrımcılıklar olmasa
kadınlar istedikleri mesleği seçebilir
seçeneklerini arttırabilir öğretmen
olmanın ötesine Hayal edebilirler
annelik ve çalışma hayatı arasında seçim
yapmaya mecbur kalmazlar Tıpkı erkekler
mecbur kalmadı gibi
bu bütün bu ev işlerini aile içi
yükümlülükleri ebeveynlik rollerini Adil
şekilde paylaştırınca kadınlarda
sırtında bir yük ile çalışmaz gereğince
performans gösterebilir
performansıyla orantılı kazanımlar elde
edebilirler aynı işi yaparken
erkeklerden daha az maaş almamış olurlar
Böylece
ve iş yerlerine ülkeye büyük faydalar
katkılar sağlayabilecek kadınlar eve
Gönderilmemiş olur bir çocuğa tek başına
bir kadın bakmadığında o çocuk iki
ebeveynine daha sağlıklı büyüyebilir
erkekler Baba olma haznını
yaşayabilirler daha sağlıklı daha
dengeli evlilikler kurulması mümkün
olabilir
Şimdi ben bunlardan bahsederken
birçoklarının aklında canım herkeste
öyle düşünmüyor Ben tabii ki toplumsal
cinsiyet eşitliğine inanıyorum bütün
erkekler de zannettiğiniz gibi değil
cümlelerinin geçtiğini biliyorum
etiketi var bunun için benim söylediğim
ise şu dünyanın en eşitlikçi insanı da
olsanız herkesten daha feministe olsanız
isteseniz de istemeseniz de erkek olarak
doğmaktan getirdiğiniz ayrıcalıklara
sahipsiniz bunun içine doğdunuz bunlar
size yüklü geldi ve Tam aksine kadın
olarak doğduğunuzda da erkeklerle denk
koşullarda değerlendirilebilmek için
Ekstra gayret göstermeniz gerekiyor
ekstra çabalamanız mücadele etmeniz
gerekiyor sistem dediğimiz biz
sen ben o toplumsal yargılar dediğimiz
bizim yargılarımız
bu eşitsizliği kırmak için herkesin
üstüne düşen bir görev var herkesin
yapabileceği en az bir şey var bugün bu
salondan çıkarken Herkesin kendi
ayrıcalıklarına kafa yormasını umut
ediyorum ayrımcılıkla mücadele etmeye
niyet etmesin niyet ediyorum ayrıcalıklı
olmak bir seçim değildi Ama ayrımcılıkla
mücadele etmeyi seçebiliriz
seçimimiz bu Olabilir çünkü Adil olan bu
kendini adaletli tanımlayan herkesin
üstüne düşen bir görev var beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim